nearly 60 percent of Americans plan to
attend a barbecue this Fourth of July
holiday weekend where some 150 million
hot dogs will be eaten which brings us
to one very special jumbo dog and 12
College grads who have landed a very
unique first job driving an American
icon across the country before they give
you the keys to go hot dogging all over
the U.S these 20-somethings are grilled
on their driving skills it's training
that has always been off limits to
cameras until now Chris Van Cleave has
the story from Madison Wisconsin
take a moment realize what's occurring
yeah this is an iconic moment
you're about to drive to Frank mobile
yeah so let's go it's happening this is
the very first time Sam delotte has been
given the keys to his new company car
but it's not just any car it's an
American icon let's get on the turn a
computer science major from Purdue he's
one of 12 recent College grads who will
spend the next year crisscrossing the
country as frankfurters the lucky dogs
behind the wheel of the Oscar Meyer
Frank mobile when I say this is a dream
country I mean cow they beat out about 2
000 other applicants to drive a 14 000
pound 11 foot tall 27 foot long hot dog
that's the equivalent of laying out 60
hot dogs end to end stacked 24 francs
High how is this thing to drive so yeah
I've never driven anything like the
frankmobile I kept catching myself
looking trying to see the rear view
mailer and there's nothing there so
there's definitely a learning curve
there felt great there are actually
eight Frank mobiles in existence six are
on the nation's roads at any one time
in teams of two these frankfurters will
steer them to about 1200 appearances do
you eat a lot of hot dogs I do frankly I
think they're delicious I'm a huge fan
but first the eight women and four guys
have to complete this driving course of
careful maneuvering more without hitting
any cones the course simulates things
like getting gas turning around and of
course parking perfect the idea is to
let the new drivers get into a pickle
here and not in the real world you're
going to be going around in circles it's
up to Sue Williams and her team of
former Madison Wisconsin police officers
to catch up these 20-somethings with the
rules of the road because no one wants a
bruised bun teaching somebody how to
maneuver a very long vehicle a very wide
vehicle is always challenging because
it's something that they've never done
how about backing up left the key she
says is teamwork stop and careful
attention
yeah
always follow all traffic laws so
there's no hot dogging in the hot tub
you're on your A-game you're polite
you're professional this is literally so
crazy what is my life Binghamton
University grad Chloe van Castle aced
what made you want to drive this across
the country adventure and the missions
this is the furthest west I've ever been
in my entire life so it'll be really
cool to see the rest of the country and
to spread Smiles along the way this
iconic rolling piece of meat is probably
better known as the Oscar Meyer
Wienermobile the name it bore since it
was cooked up by Oscar Meyer's nephew
Carl first hitting the streets of
Chicago in 1936. it was new and
revolutionary in the marketing industry
people loved it all right buddy Ed
Roland has been the wienermobile's top
dog for the last 20 years after the
Great Depression when people really
needed a little bit of joy and a little
bit of smile in their life he thought
this would be a great way to get out
there and Spark Smiles rumor has it the
original Wienermobile was recycled for
its metal to help the war effort in the
early 1940s the oldest surviving
Wienermobile dates to 1952 and is
currently on display at the Henry Ford
Museum in Detroit but for decades this
jumbo dog ended up on the back burner
back to the company's catchy TV Jingles
oh I'd love to be
[Music]
the late 1980s
Wienermobile came racing back it was
cooler than a GT
faster than a stingray and it tasted
great with mustard it was the
Wienermobile and since 1988 these big
dogs have been rolling through all 50
states year round how key to the Oscar
Meyer product is the Wienermobile oh
it's very integral it was relevant and
amazing in 88 and it is today it is a a
social media darling so why mess with a
social media darling and change the name
this year Oscar Mayer's B Franks got a
new recipe and they need it promoted is
there a difference between a wiener and
a franc actually there is a wiener has a
blended meat so it's more than one kind
of meat in the hot dog and a Frank has a
single meat and the Wienermobile got a
new name at least for now we're testing
it out this summer we've given the
wieners a love for a long time now we're
trying to give our beef frank some love
so it may not stay the Frank mobile for
decades to come well we'll have to see
if it cuts the mustard
foreign
let me relish that joke for a moment
okay cat Abraham is wrapping up her year
behind the wheel let's do it tall some
buns logging nearly 40 000 miles across
28 States I did not have a car prior to
this job and uh wait wait this is your
first car this is my first car one of
her last Frank mobile assignments
letting us ride shotgun that's their
term not mine the Frank mobile holds up
to six but does not have a kitchen its
carpet resembles condiments and its roof
is painted like a blue sky there's a bun
shaped glove box you guessed it the bun
box and the seat belts those are meat
belts more people have been to space
than have driven uh the Frank mobile and
not too many people get to ride along in
it either so what is it like to drive
this thing at first it's a bit
intimidating but once you get behind the
wheel and you get out and you see
people's reactions on the road you
realize what an honor it is our whole
job really and truly the mission is to
make people smile every day I like to
tell the hot Doggers every single day
they're making new I remember wins
because that's really what it's about
it's those memories those connections
with the people and our fans and to be
frank just about anywhere they go heads
turned and the fans come cameras in hand
to get a shot of this barbecuity making
one of those moments
Chloe van Castle can't wait to be up in
its grill for real made me a little
emotional to be honest to be getting my
buns in that seat buckling the meatball
and starting to hit the road so it's a
dream come true you could say their
primary job now is to hang out with
their Grill friends
for CBS Saturday morning I'm Chris
Vancleave in Madison Wisconsin
about all of those before he went out to
talk to everyone I just love all the
ladies the real friends was good about
girlfriends was good now what do they
have to say on the side of the Frank
mobile don't lick it maybe people try to
let the people really try to lick it
they don't try to take a bite it doesn't
say it's Simon it says that on the side
I don't know get your bun in the seat
and Buckle in your meat belts yeah there
it is we got little we got little
whistles
kvc that was a fantastic it really was
fun